they're also going to tell you who
you're allowed to be attracted to so
that was the ultimate that was the the
sort of the final shoe to drop because
that was supposed to be the most sacred
thing of all the most private and
personal thing is your sexual attraction
and nobody should have anything to say
about it no one should have any opinion
about it you could be attracted to
whoever you want in whatever way you
want and that's all there is to it man
everyone's gay once in a while and then
it turns out that well not really no
one's forcing you to date trans people
but don't cover up your discriminatory
bias in the name of preference you have
to be sexually attracted to trans people
they will berate you until you discover
within yourself a sexual attraction
trans people you know if you're a
heterosexual man that means that you're
attracted to females
okay it's not like your entire
attraction is oriented against trans
people that's not relevant you're
attracted to females and a trans person
quote-unquote trans woman a man
identified as a female actually isn't
one left is losing it